hey everybody I am genuinely glad that
you are with me today even the trolls
who are going to send me really angry
messages we have big news today in the
category of this might make Trump lose
his mind as I call it Donald Trump's
oldest son Donald Trump jr. has been
subpoenaed to testify by the Senate
Intelligence Committee and it's
important to remember that Republicans
control the Senate and therefore they
control the Senate Intelligence
Committee the chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee is Republican
Richard burr but it has actually been
that committee one of the few places
where there seems to be some sort of
bipartisan logic in dealing with the the
fiasco that is Donald Trump and
specifically the Senate Intelligence
Committee wants Donald Trump jr. to show
up and under oath to answer questions
about what were obviously lies the last
time he testified before the committee
related to his involvement in the Trump
Tower Moscow deal which ultimately
didn't end up going forward and Donald
Trump jr. previously testified about
that issue and he lied I mean he he
claimed that he had limited knowledge
about that project he claimed that there
was never really a plan it was never
really anything more than a notion that
Michael Cohen thought up and never
really touched Donald Trump jr. in any
way but unfortunately since Donald Trump
jr. told those lies to the Senate Intel
committee we found out that jr. was
lying there were significant plans for
Trump Tower Moscow a site had been
selected a builder had been selected
there were architectural permanent plans
there were many meetings about it and
maybe most importantly as it relates to
Trump Trump juniors involvement
individually we heard from Donald
Trump's former attorney Michael Cohen
who's now in prison that he was
personally briefing both Donald Trump
jr. and Ivanka Trump and others about
this
Trump Tower Moscow project and he talked
about it happening at least or roughly
10 times here's just like a few seconds
from that testimony under questioning
from congressman Stephen Lynch with his
delightful Boston accent who are the
family members that you
briefed on the Trump Tower Moscow
project tantrum Junior and Ivanka Trump
okay now with these in the regular
course of business or the president or
family requests of briefings this isn't
a regular course of business
do you recall there's a question on the
number of briefings do you recall how
many there might have been I'm sorry sir
do you recall how many of these
briefings there might have been it's
approximately 10 okay total all right
this is the opposite of what Donald
Trump jr. said under oath and now the
leaders of the Senate Intelligence
Committee who don't like being lied to
including Republican Richard burr
ranking member Democrat Mark Warner they
want Donald Trump jr. to show up again
now the fact that there is even a
subpoena is significant here because it
implies that Donald Trump jr. already
either ignored or rejected rejected an
on subpoena request to appear which
arguably forced the committee to issue
the subpoena if they actually are
determined to get him to answer
questions once again and so this is
newsworthy for a few different reasons
one of those is that again this is a
Republican lead committee and last night
I was wondering is this going to cause
infighting between Trump and his
administration and the Republicans in
the Senate and it immediately has a
source close to Donald Trump jr. has
said to CNBC that this is quote an
obvious PR stunt from a so-called
Republican senator if you want the truth
from Trump jr. if you don't want him
lying you now are apparently only a
so-called Republican according to
individuals close to Donald Trump jr. so
the infighting is starting right away
the expectation is that Trump jr. is
gonna fight this subpoena if possible
and the funniest little game they're
playing is the following CNBC is
reporting that the person close to Trump
jr. who is commenting about this says
Don is a private citizen now who has
already been cleared by special counsel
robert muller after a two-year
investigation are they really that
because there are endless other
investigations what I and others said as
soon as the Moller investigation wrapped
up was there are 12 to 14 maybe even
more depending on sort of where the
lines are between investigations there
are more than a dozen other
investigations this isn't the end
they're going to keep talking to
witnesses and a lot of people on the
right said David come on it's over this
is it there's nothing else and then now
as we see the Senate Intelligence
Committee wants Donald Trump jr. back
and the argument they're making is he's
already been cleared by Robert Muller
that's one of like 15 different
investigations that are going on the
molar probe was one thing did they
really think that it was all just going
to go away with the submission of the
Moller report or is this also a PR game
that they are playing more to curry
favor with the public than to actually
convince anybody who's in a position of
power I don't know but the most
important takeaway here is for a
republican-led committee to subpoena the
son of a Republican president in the
middle of all the chaos that's going on
right now with the Moller report with
William Barr they must believe that
Donald Trump jr. lied to them senators
don't like being lied to you if there's
one so if we think about like the
different echelons of priority among
egotistical elected officials very high
on the list is they don't like their
power questioned and that is very much
entangled with their partisanship they
want to be loyal to their party one of
the things that will more quickly than
almost anything else get Democrats and
Republicans United against some third
party is if they feel that their
position of authority and power has not
been respected and showing up and under
oath lying to them which is what there
is every indication Donald Trump jr. did
is a really quick way to get Republicans
and Democrats working together I hope
that he shows up if he fights the
subpoena we will report it and we will
tell you what ultimately happens with
this today's show was made possible in
part by better help.com slash Pakman
better help is a service that gives you
unlimited remote
access to your own fully licensed
therapist by way of phone video and text
it's less expensive than physically
going to see a therapist in an office
and you don't need to have insurance to
use better help and they stand behind
what they do better help has a
no-questions-asked full money-back
guarantee if you're not satisfied with
your experience all of better helps
counselors are thoroughly vetted for
accreditation and experience it's all
spelled out in their Terms of Service
better help requires all of its
counselors to be fully trained and
licensed and they must have at least
three years and 2,000 hours of
counseling experience so you know that
your counselor is qualified to help you
but if you don't think your counselor is
the right fit for you better help makes
it easy to switch to a new one if you've
been thinking about getting involved
with a therapist you should really check
out better help just click the link
underneath this video